للمزيد معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي عميد الياس
حنا اهلا بك المسار الذي تاخذه هذه
الهجمات او العمليات التي تستهدف المصالح
الامريكيه في المنطقه منذ بدايه الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه كيف
تراه مريم دعينا نقول اولا في البدء كانت
غزه ومن ثم
التداعيات الاقليميه اليوم المعادله التي
تحكم العلاقات الايرانيه الامريكيه هي على
الشكل التالي يعني
ايران الفريقان لا يريد لا يريدان الحرب
الشامله والكامله في المنطقه ولكن اللعبه
هي ادنى من الحرب اليوم المقاربه
الايرانيه وحده الساحات مع استقلال لكل
ساحه لتقوم بما تراه مناسبا وعندما تستهدف
القوات الامريكيه واصبحت الوتيره عاليه اي
ترد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
الميليشيات ولكن بطريقه مباشره مع قدره
ايران على النكران يعني الكل يعرف ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تريد الحرب
الشامله والكامله في المنطقه حادثه
البارحه هي حادثه تخطت الخطوط الحمر هي
داخل الاردن اولا لدينا مسرح جديد هي قتل
امريكيين 36 جريح مع ثمانيه في وضع حرج
يعني اليوم ملزمه ايران ملزم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان ترد بطريقه مختلفه
عما كنا نشاهده قبل ا كيف يمكن ان تكون
هذه الطريقه وفق قراءتك عميد الياس حنا
المتاح من الساحات وكذلك من نبره الرئيس
جو بايدن اتهام صريح لايران وتوعد بالرد
هذه المره ما الذي تتوقعه من خبرتك في هذا
التحليل اذا اذا ذهبنا الى النمط الامريكي
بالعام 2020 استهدف جنرال الرال كبير مهم
جدا هو مهندس الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه في
المنطقه الجنرال قاسم سليماني اليوم
الانتقال الى مرحله مختلفه يعني اذا لم
تكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد
الحرب الشامله والكامله يجب ان يكون الرد
الى درجه يعيد اولا ترميم الردع الامريكي
لانه تاكل منذ حرب غزه اثنين يجب ان يكون
قريب الى ايران لكن ليس الذهاب الى حرب
شامله وكامله في المنطقه ول لكنه يكون
قريبا من السمع الايراني والعين الايرانيه
كان تقول هذا الامر هذا خطر جدا اذا تم
المزيد من التصعيد سيكون هناك من التصعيد
هذا بالاضافه الى الضغوطات الامريكيه خاصه
من الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي البعض
يطلب باستهداف ايران في الداخل يعني ايران
تنكر اليوم ولكن هي من ضمن وحده الساحات
اليوم س من الضروري ان تذهب امريكا الى
مرحله متقدمه ليس كما تعودنا وليست
استهداف الميليشيات المدعومه من ايران
ولكن ذهاب الى مرحله متقدمه كما قلت اقل
من حرب ولكن اكبر من تصعيد عادي كما
تعودنا عليه اقل من حرب واكبر من تصعيد
عادي كما تعودنا عليه عميد الياس حنا لكن
هذه الفصائل او هذه الجهات التي تتوعد
باستهداف المصالح الامريكيه اذا ما لم
تتوقف هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه الى
اي مدى هي قادره على الاستمرار في هذه
المواجهه ولو كانت ربما
برد ليس فيه الكثير من التصعيد كما
ذكرت هناك تقييدات مهمه مريم في المنطقه
يعني منذ اسبوع ضربت ايران او استهدفت
ايران بصواريخ بعيده المدى دقيقه اربيل
وحتى بلوشستان وضمن سوريا وهذا من ضمن
صوره الردع الاساسيه الذي يقول ان ايران
هي قادره على استهداف كل القوات الامريكيه
وفي كل المنطقه اينما وجدت هذه القوات
ولكن هذا الامر
ايضا يضيف يضيف الساحه الاردنيه ال
الاستهداف المقبل كما قلت انه يجب ان يكون
كبير جدا الى ترميم الردع ولكن دائما يبقى
الجرح في غزه وبالتالي العمليه على وقف
هذه الحرب ولكن هذا الحدث الذي حصل في
الاردن هو في توقيت معين يعني هو في توقيت
الاجتماع في باريس والتوصل الى اتفاقات
معينه هي سنه انتخابيه للرئيس بايدن وخلال
زيارته فاذا نحن امام امريكا تقاتل عدو
شبح ولكن مدعوم من ايران تنكر ايران هذا
الامر هنا اللعبه الاساسيه انا اعتقد
اليوم الهدف يجب ان يكون مرتفع وليس كما
تعودنا عليه في المراحل السابقه العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من
بيروت شكرا جزيلا لك l